(suspenseful music)
(door handle jiggling)
(feet stomping up stairs)
(glass shattering)
(dramatic music)
- I know you're here.
If you come out I promise
I'll make it quick.
Oh, feelin' shy, are we?
If you come out I'll let you play with
this puppy.
(dramatic music)
Oh look how cute and fluffy she is.
Oh no, she's cold.
I guess I'll have to put
this little sweater on her.
(squeaking)
And of course, the ensemble
wouldn't be complete
without a tiny little police hat.
(squeaking)
Oh, who's a tiny little police officer?
You are, yes you are, yes you are.
Oh looks like our little
copper could use a friend.
(laughing)
- Oh, you're so cute.
(intense music)
Oh fuck.
(dramatic music)
Worth it.